i am having a true pinch me moment right
now because
one of my biggest dreams is actually
coming true
i am obsessed with our next guest which
is apparent in the multiple times i've
professed my love for her
during drew's news check it out
i think you might have heard what a
stalker fan
of marie kondo i am really i talk about
her all the time haven't heard i think i
scared her away
but marie i noticed that marie kondo's
picture
was facing this way and i felt like no
no no no
marie needs to face out as everyone
knows i'm completely stalking the
goddess of marie condo
i would just love her to swing by the
show i'm gonna slip into her dms
in a non-creepy way mk hi it's db
will you ever come on the show and spark
joy exclamation point laughing emoji
laughing emoji restraining order please
avoid laughing emoji
done please welcome oh my gosh
the one and only maria condo
and her interpreter mikey oh my god my
gosh
oh my gosh
i am so excited to finally meet you
i really feel uh mostly
grateful to you because you've changed
the way i look at life
like maybe my life was dormant and i
wasn't awake before you walked into it
oh i'm absolutely flattered right now to
hear that drew you
took the cone mario method and adapted
it to your life and it transformed it
that just brings joy to my heart
i heard about something called animism
when i was younger
um to believe that even objects have a
soul
and that maybe even that's what
animation came from
and my vcr used to flash and it would
give me anxiety
as if there were little men in the
machine
who were working overtime and maybe i
should just shut it off
and give them a rest i've always
believed in
magical thinking but
i wasn't looking at my joy levels
and relationship to those objects
i can't even look at a doorknob without
thinking what would marie say
you have truly mastered the konmari
method
i have a question marie when i first
discovered marie condo
i was basically a hoarder i had
15 layers to everything the chair
had a pillow and a throw blanket
and i wonder when you do
start to take away
and go layer by layer
and get to a more sane place a less
crazy place something that feels more
settled and calm
what do you do when life and kids
and the natural layers of things come
back in
it's really easy to accumulate a lot of
items and and clutter
but in those instances i work with the
children to talk to them hey what's
spark story what makes you happy and i
have them
play with and then you you integrate
them into the process
oh
oh yeah no i wasn't doing that so
now i should go with my children and
take them through their things
and figure out what sparks joy for them
and then we can
you know prioritize what we should keep
and what we should let go of is that the
right advice
absolutely talk about this with your
kids and it's very important that at a
young age they understand what it means
to spark joy and what sparks joy to them
you have a new online tidying course
will you please tell us about that so we
can all watch it and learn
absolutely so what this is is a visual
guide
to the tagging process and of course if
you read the book
some people can visualize it but this
really helps because it is a very visual
medium to see the process how it gets
done and
help people go through the entire
process of tidying up
last week i was mesmerized by how you
fold
underwear the underwear you chose
um were uh very petite
and i tend to wear something that looks
more like a parachute
like if there's a fire we should all
grab my underwear
and like use it um how would you
fold um like a fitted sheet
or my underwear
so you want to take the most important
bits and fold it to the top like so
in word
oh you could fold it in half
because this is cotton and it's a very
rigid fabric
you don't have to fold it as many times
okay
perfect i appreciate you so
much what you've put into the world
you've
helped and allowed and normalized us
asking what joy is and
how we find it i i think i'm going to
have to pinch myself
i just want to say marie that i
i truly
hope to make you proud
i i i have your picture
on my desk and i hope that i haven't
scared you away
i am ecstatic right now let's go spread
more joy around the world
yes
oh my gosh go to the drewberrymore
show.com for more information on marie's
online class
the con mari method fundamentals of
[Music]
tidying